my name is Mecca lalola and I'm they had
corporate complications of rondo plc
Nigeria's leading integrated energy
solutions provider and I'm a Nigerian
and the question of you to contributing
to you positive change in Africa in the
short term is a very interesting one
particularly because you know
demographic studies show that youth in
Africa today constitute about sixty
percent of the entire population so it
means that they're a critical number a
critical mass of what the future holds
for the continent and if we marshal if
we govern eyes the energies of our youth
in the right direction you see a lot of
change a lot of positive change towards
growth economic growth and economic
empowerment for even generations after
them an interesting point as we made on
facebook is that it shouldn't just be
good for the sake of growth but it
should be sustainable growth and one of
the avenues that have been touted to be
a veritable I'm interest to you to be in
a area of social enterprise okay the
ability to ensure that whatever venture
you're engaging has a net positive
impact on the society at large you know
you know so that's why we're inculcating
the discipline of enterprising are used
you should be mindful of not just profit
but people and the planet as well and I
strongly believe that if we adapt this
philosophy of
this inclusive philosophy of providing
value across the value chain and not
just from a very myopic lake point of
view of profit we will be building a
sustainable society you know for
generations to come you know so when you
say that the use of the future of
society we're not just looking at the
immediate future we are building a
sustainable future for Africa so i think
is very interesting that anyone will
point out you know they be the concepts
of being involved in you know green jobs
or you know shoe shoe shoe shoe
enterpreneurship Naruto that does a very
good point to make the second paint and
lastly is that there is a positive
correlation between conflicts tribe you
know restiveness in Africa and lack of
economic empowerment in use you know
because once you don't provide the youth
with the enabling environment should
contribute to development you do all the
energies who have to go into something
sometimes it goes into is channeling to
negative negative you know it's very
real from from a negative standpoint so
I would say that you know as a matter of
deliberate policy you know leadership
across Africa should engage you know
from a very delicate point of view I'm
in clusters you know it could be from
original point of view you know looking
at nation-states you know by nation
states you know a very strong program to
ensure that the youth engaged you know
and welcome to world economic forum on
africa next year in the next leader
the couple of years we will see
appreciable change and we see a lot of
contribution you know fell from the use
in this regard thank